[Music]
tonight comedians Andy Daly and TIG
Notaro here we've got some fresh-baked
Boehner coming at you if you're smelling
toast it's not a stroke this is talking
bread
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to talking Fred I'm your host
Chris Hardwick this is the one and only
show where bread heads like you and I
can come together and geek out about our
favorite carb the only carb as far as
I'm concerned though that may not be
technically accurate here's how it works
we're gonna spend the next hour talking
about bread and that's it there's
nothing more so if you've got grain on
the brain get ready to release the yeast
in the healthy way let's meet tonight's
panel
first of all comedian Andy Daly how are
you Andy good how are you and also a
comedian TIG Notaro also here now which
widget which is your favorite hand to
put bread into your mouth with oh that's
a great question I mean when it comes
like if I'm eating a sandwich or
something like that a lot of the time at
the beginning of the sandwich when it's
at its biggest I'll definitely be using
both hands yeah but by the time it gets
smaller because I'm right-handed
I'll usually be down to my right hand
yeah sometimes if it's a bag yet I'll
use my left hand because it feels like
someone else's Oh interesting yeah like
a Frenchman's hand exactly I'll tell you
what I like to do and I don't know maybe
this is just me but sometimes I like to
do like a half but sandwich where you
take the end of the loaf and the bottom
part is really kind of like the Mattress
of the sandwich you just take two heels
and one slice of bread in the middle of
the heels that's actually not a bad idea
never thought to do that you're actually
just making a bread sandwich out of the
heels and then it's the world's tiniest
low yeah yeah let's start with something
that's been in the news lately
it's one of these buzz words that the
media is just having a field day with
and that's toast so what do you guys
like to put on toast
sounds great question I think you guys
are probably gonna make fun of me for
this but I mean I'm old school about it
like I just go back to just butter you
know what I'm saying you said old school
so I thought you're gonna say you know
like rosewater and butterscotch candies
really old school this is a question for
TIG is there anything that you wouldn't
put on toast uh it's a tough one cake
well yeah maybe I wouldn't put cake on
toast my pork a cantos a little bit of
cake yeah red velvet yeah like a red
velvet cake or a chocolate lab yeah it
wouldn't be bad
it doesn't feel necessary but it
wouldn't be bad yours at home by the way
can join in by live tuning with a
hashtag ruin a piece of toast and enjoy
these epic toasts fails
[Laughter]
[Music]
those people okay let's read some
questions from the fans right this is
from glutton for glutton my doctor
recently told me that eating bread is
inflaming my eczema what are some
gluten-free sandwich options here's what
I would say the gluten-free sandwich
that's called the salad up top this is
from Doughboy 73 if you were trapped in
the zombie apocalypse with only one type
of bread what would it be I truly enjoy
hot dog buns oh that's good yeah I would
go with a marble rye why is that over a
hot dog box I think so yeah I just kind
of like the swirl I kind of like the
ebony and ivory of it all cuz you know I
was a big Jackson McCartney fan that was
Stevie and I'm sorry I was a big
McCartney Stevie Wonder fan that's why I
Bini and ivory was Jackson McCartney no
I think it was a girl I'm pretty I'm
pretty sure that it was the girl is mine
was Jackson McCartney yeah it was Stevie
Wonder and Paul McCartney for every yeah
no well I mean I was and II was Paul
McCartney and Michael Jackson and II you
don't have to you could easily solve
this with this do you want some bread
how about a breadstick now we have a
ceremony on this show when we have a
disagreement yeah the guests and I
actually have to eat from the same bread
stick in order to make peace touch the
bottom okay
why did you stop he pulled away this is
from at on a roll
what's the most sensual bread shape I
guess I'd have to say probably the bread
bowl yeah I'm saying because something's
going in there mm-hmm I would have to
say a bread [ __ ] oh I didn't know that
I haven't yeah I haven't seen this will
you I've seen a Cinnabon yeah is that
what that is you can manipulate one yeah
sounds like any bread could be a bread
[ __ ] um yeah I mean I guess that's true
but I would I don't think anybody should
fashion any kind of bread into it what
what we're talking about but if you were
gonna do it I guess I'd nominate the
PETA I would have to second that
nomination yeah we were very special
guests tonight please welcome Frank an
assistant Baker at the La Brea bakery
[Applause]
rosemary you bet don't Bogart that man
Wow thank you now Andy yeah we're
totally right look at that yeah you can
anyone any little origami what's your
favorite hit by the band bread.if who's
a good one uh do you guys consider bread
a jam band and is that a good joke no
and no okay no I liked it well this is a
moment we've all been waiting for
it is time to play stump the baker Frank
can you name all nine grains in nine
grain bread there's an easy way to
remember barley buck wheat corn and flex
millet oats and rye white wheat red
wheat you're all that's yep I liked it
the last two were just sort of an
afterthought it's yeah it's how I
learned it as a kid how is that an easy
way to remember it when we come back
Colin Hanks of the hit series Fargo
takes us behind the scenes of his
pantry and later get out of my shot and
later we'll play He Who smelt it dealt
it stick around for more talking bread
unfortunately talking bread has just
been canceled because bread is dumb but
stay tuned for the premiere of talking
red tonight Sofia Vergara and Jon Hamm
talk about their favorite color
I hope it's red plus blood oranges are
they the new oranges find out on talking
red
you